Sacrifice and we'll,
we'll talk more about that too.
You get to pick your damn sacrifice.
That's all.
You don't get to not make what your sacrificial,
whether you want to be or not.
That's a good thing to know as well.
So even though it's rather,
you know,
it's rough thing to figure out,
but other questions
I haven't had no one else.
Okay.
Nothing you just said about noticing and more and more and people live into
their 20s yeah.
What do you think about that?
Where do you think that comes from in terms of culture?
We live in,
think universities facilitated
because you can go to university to not be something instead of going to
university to be something and,
and that's it's pleasure island
and the price you pay for it,
especially in the u s is debt and you're enticed into it because the
administrators can pick your pocket.
So they rob your future self while allowing you to pretend that you have an
identity.
Right.
Very nasty.
And you can't declare bankruptcy with your student loans in the U S it's
indentured servitude and it,
it is player.
It's precisely pleasure island.
It's exactly that.
And so tuition fees of short way out of control.
And part of the reason that universities don't make more demands on their
students and let them get away with all the things,
they let them get away with this because they're basically,
why the hell would you chase them out?
There are $100,000 or more so they can do whatever they want as long as you get
to sell them to the salt mines.
Right.
So,
and you know,
it's not the only reason because the other thing that's happened is that the
rate of technological transformation is so fast now and the rate of turnover of
things is that it's,
it is genuinely harder for people who are say 18 to 20 when I was a kid,
roughly speaking,
the kind of rough patch for,
for for life was probably 14 to 17 something like that.
Now it's,
I think it's 18 to 25 something like that.
And I think the reason for that is,
is that all the jobs that the bloody hippies complained about being doomed to in
the 1960s have now disappeared.
Their problem was,
oh my God,
I'm going to be,
I go have to work for a corporation and get a salary for the rest of my life,
you know,
and then I'll just end up with a pension and that'll be my whole life.
It's like,
well,
it seems like a lot better deal then an endless round of part time Starbucks
jobs.
So you know,
some of it is that it's,
it's just,
it's,
there's a space now in our culture that that is lacking for people to make that
transformation from,
from adolescence into adulthood.
And so it's just,
it's,
the cost of that is for stalled,
but it's not a good thing.
It's not a good thing.
Do you think this is affecting employers picky and choosy younger people for a
job?
Are you saying that the,
they're seeing this Laura maturation or this or saying this person's got a
degree from UFT,
but I've heard about things like degrees out worth birthday.
Well,
the,
there's a couple of problems with the degrees is that everyone has one.
That's the first one,
which,
so because scarcity matters obviously.
Um,
the second thing is,
is that the match between the degree in the workplace has become less and less
self evident.
You know what should happen when you go to university is you should learn how to
think and formulate arguments.
You should learn to think,
speak and write.
That's what the humanities are for.
They're to make you dangerous,
right?
Because if you can think and speak and write your deadly in a complex job,
you're exactly what's necessary.
But if you don't have that,
it's like what the hell good is the degree.
So I mean,
degree in English literature doesn't prepare you for a job.
It could make you think,
write and speak,
which prepares you for any complex job.
And that's what's supposed to happen.
But increasingly I think,
okay,
that doesn't happen.
Okay.
And the employers are waking up to this very rapidly,
so and there,
I mean,
they've already known that most for most complex positions,
they have to train their people.
Now they're thinking,
well,
why do I have to bother with the degree if I'm going to train them?
If it isn't bringing anything of value?
You see this.
And even it feels like law.
When I went to do a debate at Queen's university three weeks ago,
I think they couldn't get anybody to debate me.
You know,
they,
the guy had to pay,
play devil's advocate.
We were talking about bill see 16.
I thought,
Jesus,
that's so pathetic.
I'm talking about legal matters.
And I meant the word greatest didn't one of the greatest universities in the
West,
you know what I mean?
It's in the top 200,
let's say.
Um,
I couldn't get someone to argue with the stupid psychology professor about law,
had to get a devil's advocate.
And so one of the things that was really disheartening talking to the students
was they told me four or five of them,
they're not learning a damn thing and lights all social justice nonsense.
It's like,
well good,
that'll do it in the profession.
It's being done in any ways because lawyers being replaced by automation.
And so a lot of what they do is dig up information.
It's like,
well,
you can do that on your own.
And forums are proliferating like mad.
So the law school should be teaching you to be a monster.
You better be,
but you come out,
you're concerned with social welfare.
Oh God.
It's like,
well,
there's just nothing to that.
It's like you can come out and say you're,
you want to be nice to people.
Well,
that's nice.
Good.
You go right ahead.
It's like,
I'll go find someone who can do something and you can go be nice to people and
see how effective that is.
So it's a lot of things that are conspiring in the same direction.
People don't have to get married to have sex,
so we have no idea what that's going to do.
Although we know one thing it's done is the only people to get married now,
or rich.
Okay.
Right.
Which is another thing that's really comical because the feminist id in the 60s
was that marriage was an oppressive,
oppressive,
patriarchal institution.
It's like,
okay,
fine then why do only rich women get married now?
Because that's the,
that is the case.
And so for poorer women,
the dissolution of marriage has been an absolute catastrophe.
They are so screwed because they have kids.
So they're working,
they've got their 90 hour work week,
man,
that's for sure.
They're much less attractive to potential mates.
So they get low quality men,
often parasitical and predatory.
So they often have like jobs in retail for example,
which are just dreadful.
You don't even know what your schedule is going to be.
You get paid hardly anything.
You know,
it's really,
but if you know,
most of the women who,
who,
who are outspoken feminists are on the successful end of the socioeconomic
distribution.
They're university students or people like that.
They don't even know any poor women.
So they have no idea what their lives are like.
And you would never know,
cause they're at home working,
you know,
they're either at their horrible job or they're at home slaving away with their
kids.
So it's not like they're out there telling you what's wrong with them.